so after Facebook you started social
capital or what what is now called
Social Capital what have you learned
from all the successful investing you've
done there
about investing or about life yeah or
about running a team if I'm very loath
to give advice because I think it's so
much of it is situational but my
observation is that starting a business
is really hard any kind of business
and most people don't know what they're
doing
and as a result we make enormous
mistakes
but I would summarize this and this may
be a little heterodoxical I think there
are only three kinds of mistakes because
if we go back to what we said before in
the business
it's just learning you're exploring the
dark space to get to the answer faster
than other people
and those the mistakes that you make are
three
or the three kinds of decisions let's
say
you'll hire somebody
and
they're really really really average but
they're a really good person
oh yeah
you'll hire somebody
and they really weren't candid with who
they are and their real personality and
their morality and their ethics only
expose them
over a long period of time
and then you hire somebody
and uh they're not that good
uh morally but they're highly performant
what do you do with those three things
and I think successful companies
have figured out how to answer those
three things because those are the
things
that in my opinion determine success and
failure so it's basically hiring and you
just identified three failure cases for
hiring but very different failure cases
and very complicated ones right like the
highly performant person who's not that
great as a human being do you keep them
around well a lot of people would air
towards keeping that person around what
is the right answer I don't know it's
the context of the situation
um and the second one is also very
tricky what about if they really turned
out that they were just not candid with
who they are and it took you a long time
to figure out who you were these are all
mistakes of the senior person that's
running this organization
I think if you can learn
to manage those situations well
those are the real edge cases where you
can make mistakes that are fatal to a
company
yeah that's what I've learned over 11
and a half years honestly otherwise the
business of investing
I feel that it's like a it's a secret
and if you are willing to just keep
chipping away
you'll peel back enough of these you
know
layers will come off and you'll see if
the scales will come off and you'll
eventually see it I really struggle with
maybe you can be my therapist for a
little bit well that first case which
you originally mentioned because I love
people I see the good in people I really
struggle with just a mediocre performing
person who's who's a good human being
that's a tough one
I'll let you off the hook yeah I think
those are incredibly important and
useful people I think that if a company
is like a body they are like cartilage
can you replace cartilage yeah but would
you if he didn't have to no
okay can I can I play Devil's Advocate
yeah so those folks
because of their goodness
make it okay to be mediocre
they they create a culture where well we
what's important in life which is
something I agree in my personal life is
to be good to each other to be friendly
to be good vibes all that kind of stuff
you know when I was at Google just like
the good atmosphere everyone's playing
and just it's fun fun right
um but to me
like when I when I put on my hat of like
having a mission and a goal what I love
to see is the superstars that shine for
some in some way like do something
incredible and I want everyone to also
admire that those Superstars and perhaps
not just for the productivity's sake or
performing or successful company's sake
but because that too is an incredible
thing that humans are able to accomplish
which is shine I hear you but that's not
a decision you make meaning you get
lucky when you have those people in your
company
that's not the hard part for you the
hard part is figuring out what to do
with one two and three yeah keep demote
promote fire what do you do
and this is why it's all about those
three buckets I personally believe that
folks in that bucket one
as long as those folks aren't more than
50 to 60 percent of a company are good
and they can be managed as long as they
are one to two degrees away from one of
those people that you just mentioned
yeah
yeah because it's easy then to drag the
entire company down if they're too far
away from the LeBron James because you
don't know what LeBron James looks and
feels and smells and you know so you
need that tactile sense of what
Excellence looks like in front of you
a great example is if you like if you
just go on YouTube and you search these
clips of how Kobe Bryant's teammates
described not Kobe but how their own
behavior
not performance because there's a bunch
of average people that Kobe played with
this whole career but their behavior
changed
by being somewhat closer to him and I
think that's an important psychological
thing to note
for how you can do reasonably good team
construction if you're lucky enough to
find those generational talents
you have to find a composition of a team
that keeps them roughly close
to enough of the org that way that
group of people
can continue to add value and then
you'll have courage to fire these next
two groups of people and I think the
answer is to fire those two groups of
people because no matter how good you
are that stuff just injects poison into
a into a living organism and that living
organism will die when exposed to poison
so would you invest in a lot of
companies you've looked at a lot of
companies what do you think makes for a
good leader so we talked about building
a team but a good leader for a company
what are the qualities
you know I um when I first meet people
um I never asked to see a resume
um
and when I'm meeting a Company CEO for
the first time I couldn't care less
about the business in fact
um and I try to take the time
to let them reveal themselves now in
this environment you know I'm doing most
of the talking but if this were the
other way around and you were ever
raising capital and usage moth I'd be
interested in you looking at this
business
I'd probably say eight to ten words
for hours and just listen prod you know
I throw things out prod and let you
Meander and in you Meandering I'm trying
to build a sense of who this person is
once I have a rough sense of that which
is not necessarily right but it's a
starting point
then I can go and understand why this
idea makes sense in this moment and what
I'm really trying to do is just kind of
like unpack where are the biases that
may make you you know fail
and then we go back to you
the thing that Silicon Valley has the
benefit of though is that they don't
have to do any of this stuff
if there's momentum because then the
rule book goes out the window and people
clamor to invest so one of the things
that I do
and this is again back to this pugilism
that I inflict on myself
is I have these two things that I look
at thing number one is I have a table
that says
how much did we make from all of our
best investments how much did we lose
from all of our worst Investments what
is the ratio of winners to losers over
11 years
and in our case it's 23 to 1. on you
know billions of dollars so you can you
can kind of like you can see a lot of
signal
but what that allows me to do is really
like say wait a minute like we cannot
violate these rules around how much
money we're willing to commit in an
errant personality you know the second
is I ask myself of all the other top VCS
in Silicon Valley name them all you know
um what's our correlation meaning
when I do a deal how often does anybody
from Sequoia Excel Benchmark Kleiner who
you name it
do it at the same time or after
and vice versa and then then I look at
the data to see how much they do it
amongst themselves
what's a good sign I'm at zero as
virtually close to zero as possible
that's a good thing well
it's not a good thing when the markets
are way way up
because it creates
an enormous amount of momentum so I have
to make money the hard way I have to you
know because I'm trafficking and things
that are highly uncorrelated
to the the Gestalt of Silicon Valley
which can be a lonely business
but it's really valuable in moments
where markets get crushed because
correlation is the first thing that
causes massive destruction of of capital
massive because one person all of a
sudden with one blow up in one company
Boom the contagion hits everybody except
the person that was you know not and so
now those are like more sophisticated
elements of risk management which is
again this pugilism that I inflict on
nobody asks me to do that nobody
actually at some level when the markets
are up really care that when markets are
sideways or when markets are down I
think that
that allows me to feel proud of our
process
you know but that requires you to think
a lot a lot outside the box it's lonely
because you're taking risks also your
public personality so you say stuff that
if it's wrong you get yelled at for
constantly for uh for being I mean your
mistakes aren't private no and that's
something that
um has been a really really healthy
moment of growth
it's like an athlete you know
if you really want to be a winner you
got to hit the shot
in front of the fans
and if you miss it you have to be
willing to take the responsibility of
the fact that you bricked it
and over time hopefully there's a body
of work that says you've generally hit
more than you've missed
but if you look at even the best
Shooters what are they 52 percent
so these are razor thin margins at the
end of the day which is really so then
what can you control
I can't control the defense I can't
control what they throw at me I can just
control my preparation and whether I'm
in the best position to launch a
reasonable shot